on va retrouvé à quelques centaines
kilomètres de là notre envoyé spécial
thomas abonnés thomas vous suivez cette
journée d'élection se dit d en direct
donc de new york où semble-t-il savoir
assez peu aujourd'hui
oui assez paradoxalement il n'y a pas
vraiment de files d'attentes devant les
bureaux de vote alors il y avait un peu
de monde ce matin à l'ouverture depuis
ce moment-là il s'est un peu plus calme
mais il ya évidemment des électeurs qui
se rendent aux urnes assez régulièrement
mais pas de files d'attentes comme on a
pu voir depuis maintenant dix jours dix
jours que les bureaux de vote sont
ouverts ici à new york beaucoup ont donc
choisi le vote par anticipation certains
ont également choisi le vote par
courrier ce matin avant l'ouverture des
bureaux de vote pour sept derniers jours
ce dernier jour des élections
il y avait déjà 100 millions
d'américains qui avaient voté on a plus
de 70 % du taux de participation totale
de l'élection de 2016 on verra si la
participation continue d'augmenter avec
l'affluence s'est pour le moment pas
vraiment le cas ici à new york où les
électeurs ont semble-t-il fait le choix
de voter en avance
alors quand on a parlé avec ses
électeurs c'est pendant ces derniers
jours il était évidemment très désireux
d'un changement ici à new york la
plupart des électeurs sont du côté des
démocrates c'est pas un secret
évidemment beaucoup souhaitent que trump
quitte la maison blanche mais on leur a
également posé des questions autour des
tensions qui peuvent exister vous en
avez parlé également avec vos invités
sur cette amérique fracture est divisée
et la preuve de cette division ce sont
ces barricades qui se dresse sur un
certain nombre de commerces à new york
mais aussi dans d'autres villes des
états unis sur la cinquième avenue qui
est une avenue où il ya beaucoup de
boutiques de luxe notamment et bien des
planches de bois sont installés sur
quasiment tous les commerces ils
redoutent en fait que des manifestations
d'ampleur puisse être organisé à après l
annonce des résultats en même temps même
pendant la confusion qui pourraient
suivre
la nonne annonces de résultats ils
craignent qu'ils puissent avoir des
débordements
manifestation c'est aussi la crainte
d'un certain nombre d'électeurs avec
lesquels j'ai pu échanger ces derniers
jours qui redoute évidemment que des
affrontements plus avoir lieu puisque il
ya dix jours à peine ici à times square
et quelques mètres de là des supporters
de donald trump s'étaient violemment
affrontés avec des des supporters de joe
biden en tout cas des personnes qui
n'aiment pas donald trump c'était une
des nouvelles illustrations de cette
atmosphère tendue ici
évidemment les prises de parole de
chacun des deux candidats seront
observés avec attention si l'un ou
l'autre venait à revendiquer ou à
contester une ébauche des résultats on à
donald trump qu'il ya quelques instants
a déclaré que les américains étaient en
droit de connaître le résultat le soir
de l'élection on sait que dans les faits
ce sera bien plus complexe puisqu'il ya
beaucoup de votes par courrier de vote
par anticipation et que tout ça va
prendre du temps pour l'écoulement
merci thomas bonnet en direct donc de
new york qui ont